President Trump is asking Americans to
be safe but also accept the risk of
spreading the virus in order to restart
the economy during a meeting with nurses
at the White House yesterday the
president also talked about changing his
mind about disbanding the White House
coronavirus task force Paula Reed
reports from the White House I had no
idea how popular the task force is until
actually yesterday President Trump said
the task force would remain active
indefinitely but will shift its focus to
economic recovery as he met with nurses
serving on the frontlines of the
pandemic the President had a message to
Americans as he acknowledged more lives
could be lost as businesses reopen these
people worries and I'm actually calling
now as you know John the nation wars you
have to be warriors medical experts and
lawmakers have argued that there needs
to be widespread testing before the
country reopens and while the president
and members of the White House are
regularly tested the president's new
press secretary said it wasn't necessary
for the entire population the notion
that everyone needs to be tested is just
simply nonsensical the people who need
to be tested are vulnerable populations
the president also called dr. Rick
bright a government vaccine expert who
filed a whistleblower complaint alleging
the administration ignored early warning
signs a disgruntled employee I don't
know who he is
I didn't hear good things about him I
did not hear good things about him at
all but it's not the only whistleblower
complaint filed against the
administration CBS News has learned of a
separate complaint that alleges the
president's son-in-law Jared Kushner
tasked a group of young inexperienced
volunteers with securing vital medical
supplies for the Cova drous Ponce
according to a source at FEMA the task
force may have steered government
contracts to associates and political
allies President Trump said he didn't
know much about the effort but defended
his son-in-law I think they did an
incredible job now I don't know anything
about any of the details of it but it
was a well-oiled machine they were
to get things that nobody else was able
to get simius News has also learned that
these volunteers use their personal
email accounts and not their government
accounts to conduct official business in
order to do that you need a waiver
otherwise it can raise serious legal
issues and it's not clear if that
special permission was given here
FEMA source also tells CBS News that
using Gmail accounts added to confusion
and delays specifically saying that
often contractors would receive an email
and they weren't sure if it was from an
imposter or an actual government
official Gail Paula thank you reporting
from the White House today